la force barca n'aurait-elle commis des
bavures au sahel l'armée française
réfutent cette hypothèse
mediapart fait pourtant état de trois
bavures récentes
la france est même soupçonné de
pratiques et des frappes signature ses
frappes menées couramment par les
américains ont pour principe de viser
des groupes d'individus dans les
caractéristiques semblerait lié à une
activité terroriste mais dont l'identité
n'est pas établie et qui ne sont pas en
train de combattre depuis janvier 2013
la france est engagée militairement au
sahel pour l'opération barkan débuter en
elle emploie simply 100 soldats français
déployés sur cinq pays mauritanie mali
burkina faso niger et tchad
elle reçoit l'appui logistique des
etats-unis notamment en matière de
drones de surveillance et de frappe mais
sur un aussi vaste terrain avec le
manque de soutien de certains pays de la
bande sahélo saharienne
les groupes armés se sont disséminés ont
gagné du terrain et les villageois sont
souvent forcés de pactiser avec eux même
s'ils n'adhèrent pas à leur idéologie
dans ce contexte les forces spéciales
françaises opèrent avec le plus grand
soin pour identifier les djihadistes et
ne pas faire de dommage collatéral
l'américanisation du conflit il d
humanisation des frappes peut conduire à
des bavures
le cas le plus emblématique est la
frappe française sur le village de
bounty au mali le 3 janvier dernier
l'armée dit avoir touché un
rassemblement de djihadistes problème
quelques jours plus tard des civils se
plaignent que le rassemblement
résultaient en fait de la célébration
d'un mariage
l'armée a aussitôt nié qu'il s'agissait
d'une telle célébration aucun dommage
collatéral
aucun élément constitutif d'un
rassemblement festif ou d'un mariage n'a
été observée la mission des nations
unies au mali la minus m'a alors enquêté
mené 200 entretiens s'est rendu sur le
site de la frappe a analysé des images
pour elle il s'agissait bien d'un
mariage les frappes auraient tué certes
trois jihadistes une katiba mais surtout
19 innocent et elle recommande
d'examiner de manière approfondie les
processus de mise en oeuvre des
précautions lors de la préparation d'une
frappe ainsi que des critères utilisés
pour déterminer la nature militaire de
l'objectif réponse de l'armée une mise
en doute du rapport de l'onu on retrouve
les mêmes conclusions de la part du site
d'information de newman et aryan
du journal allemand der spiegel qui ont
enquêté sur le bilan civil de la
garantie djihadistes de la france au
mali après bounty six jeunes auraient
péri dans des frappes françaises le 25
mars dernier
selon des élus locaux contactés par
mediapart six jeunes de 16 à 20 ans
n'ont jihadi c'était juste parti chasser
le lapin de newman et therion affirme
que 56 civils ont probablement été tués
par les forces françaises depuis 2013
alors que l'armée française dans concède
que cette ce bilan fâcheux interroge sur
la capacité des français à utiliser les
drones sans dommages collatéraux
emmanuel macron confronté à l'enlisement
aux banques d'investissement des
dirigeants locaux et aux coups d'état au
mali a annoncé mettre fin à l'opération
de barkan la fin de l'opération barkan
en tant qu'opération extérieur pour
permettre une opération d'appui de
soutien et de coopération aux armées des
pays de la région qui le souhaitent et
de la mise en oeuvre d'une opération
militaire et d'une alliance
internationale associant les états de la
région et tous nos partenaires
strictement concentrer sur la lutte
contre le terrorisme
cela signifie t'il la fin d'éventuelles
bavures non car des forces resteront sur
place et surtout la prédominance
aérienne va persister les drones vont
survoler ces armes dont barack obama a
fait un usage immodéré ne font pas
toujours la différence entre les civils
et les djihadistes pendant ce temps la
grande muette sort de sa réserve pour
s'absoudre